[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsay
show and it's where america is hanging
out to have a conversation about your
life i'm ken coleman i'm joined by my
colleague ramsey personality
george camel the phone number to jump in
on the conversation today is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
i will uh dive in on your work questions
you wanna get a bigger shovel ken i
wanna get promoted how do i make more
money so i could speed up
the baby steps i'm your guy
i'll help you get a bigger shovel uh
some of you going ken i just need help
because i don't enjoy what i do i'm on
my way i'm paying off debt i'm wanting
to know can i work the baby steps but
also take steps towards doing work that
i really really love pursuing the dream
is that possible the answer is yes we'll
take on your specific situation and of
course george is here our money guru
he's going to help you with your money
questions as well and so
it may be the day for some of you to
call in and go you know what uh
i need to call i'm nervous about calling
uh we will change your name and your
location
we understand that these questions many
times many times are very very sensitive
george and we have no problem changing
your name and location so that you feel
confident to call in and get some help
so we are here standing by triple eight
eight two five five two two five got
some fun stuff we're gonna cover today
george you doing well i'm doing
fantastic you just had the minimalists
on your show yeah it must have been a
good time good time and uh i must say uh
for those that will uh see you on
youtube today uh this shirt is very
interesting i don't find that uh you are
much of a football fan from what i know
of you and yet you have miniature
classic old football players and uh
footballs all over your shirt today i i
think it's irony and i find humor and
irony so you bought it because you
thought this will be a funny shirt to
wear pretty much yeah you ever do that
no okay just me yeah i i don't try to be
funny but but i like what you're doing
there it's a great shirt it's football
season there's probably a big game
somewhere yeah this weekend so oh i see
you just you sat back and i see that
you've got a grill yeah it's it's just
football culture grilling football yeah
all right and george just learned
recently what football is so that makes
it even more this is why you've got to
watch the show yeah you get to see
things like that that's exactly right in
hd maybe we'll have the guys zoom in on
your shirt later in the program and
we'll do a full diagram and break down
but let's get to the phones that's why
we're here to help you it is your show
we're going to start off with marcia who
joins us in atlanta georgia marcia how
can we help
oh
thanks for taking my call you bet um
my husband and i um
have been working the ramsey plan about
two years ago and
we sold our home and we paid off over
140 000 worth of credit card bills wow
140 000 in credit card bills
yes my husband was
uh i guess he was just caught up in uh
trying to get
extra cards to pay you know and transfer
uh
balances and just got caught up in a lot
of credit cards what was he buying
well we had we were uh you could call it
living to be that local
living
that's great i love this
but you know what matters marcia is that
you guys got on the same page and paid
this off that's unbelievable
yes we did well now
yeah we are in a situation um that i
really need some help with uh we have
over 300 300 000 worth of student loans
uh between myself and him
and we have
five investment properties three we own
outright and two we have a mortgage on
and
you know we're thinking should we sell
uh
investment properties to just get this
student loan out of our lives that's the
only
debt that we have now or should we
continue to rent these properties and
just use our income to pay off the
student loans what is your household
income
our household income is about 200 000
okay
great income there
and you've got 300 000 student loans
making 200. i mean if you wanted to if
you wanted to get intense you can just
use your income and pay off these
student loans now if i'm in your shoes
and i've got five rental properties uh
two of them having a mortgage on them i
want you to be completely debt free as
soon as possible so if i'm you i'm
selling one or two of those mortgage pro
properties to pay off these loans what
are these properties worth
well um
they were they're both worth about 200
000 but one of i mean we paid dirt cheap
for them like 20 000 so
well
the mortgage for all the mortgage
properties sorry um the mortgage
property probably about two hundred and
fifty thousand and one is worth two
hundred thousand so what do you have
what do you owe on each
on on the one that's worth
two hundred thousand we owe 68 000 on
that one
and the other one we owe
123.
wow
so there's your answer i'm hearing if
you sell the two with the mortgage on
them you could pretty much be debt-free
like tomorrow yes and you still have
three paid for properties
right i put a ha i put a sign in the
yard of both of those two that you have
a mortgage on today
oh that that that is good yes that's
what i was thinking that's what i
thought you all would say
well you are thinking properly
i'm glad we could give you some
confirmation there well you guys have
done really well on that side i think
you were just doing some things out of
order and now once you pay off these
student loans you've got three paid for
properties you're gonna really build
some wealth and my take is that you're
gonna buy your next properties with cash
yeah and most definitely that's what
we're thinking i love it well you guys
have done really well we're cheering for
you get rid of these properties get rid
of these student loans way to go marcia
and you know what's great uh you could
hear the husband in the background like
they're all in yeah and you know what i
really loved about that call when we
first you know started talking to her
and you asked what was the debt they
paid off like 140 000 and credit card
debt and you were like what was that and
she was like
my husband and it's so sweet in that he
was completely off the reservation and
somewhere in that story we didn't get it
they got on the same page yeah and paid
off 140 000 dollars with a credit card
debt and now look at them
he was clear they're doing they're
willing to do whatever it takes even
though they've made some mistakes
they're they're owning up and going we
don't want to live this way anymore
we're done live in la vida loca oh yeah
that's what was great that was the life
that needs to decide we're done live in
la vida loca it's smoking mirrors it's a
house of cards yeah you know what i'm
embarrassed to say i don't actually know
what that means okay
yes
very popular ricky martin song back in
the late 90s early 2000s i'll remember i
am embarrassed to say i forgot i it felt
familiar to me but i was like i can't
place it i'm wanting to sing it on air
but i think the fcc might shut us down
oh we don't want to do that i want all
the license for a lot of reasons what
does it mean though uh it means living
living the crazy life ah thank you for
living the good life you know
i didn't right oh i didn't know they're
laughing at me in the control room i
don't mind okay i just taught you some
spanish can i feel pretty good i feel a
little bit more valuable who says you
can't teach an old dog new tricks
well you know i would take offense of
that but compared to you george i am the
old dog and i might as well just own it
hey uh folks we're just getting started
we're here to help you on your money
questions you want to get a bigger
shovel you want more out of your life
and work george and i are here together
teaming up to help you
somebody needs to call triple eight
eight two five five two two five don't
move more of your calls and more of the
ramsay show coming right up
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
slash ken sign up today absolutely free
and let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
welcome back america you have joined the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman joined by
my colleague george campbell we're
taking you through this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five
two two five
uh
boy i'm gonna take a stab at this one i
like to say that i'm hooked on phonics
george and i'm looking at the board i'm
gonna go it's uh
euclare
wisconsin we'll see ken joins us there
oh close eau claire oh i blew it ken i'm
so sorry how can we help
hi my name is ken yeah it's a good name
it is a cool name
hey uh i've been an artist my whole life
i've made excellent money i've actually
uh paid off my mortgage 20 year 10 years
ago wow with with the sales of art but
ever since then life kind of took a real
deep turn and
i've been underemployed
and i i it's all i needed to hear was
your philosophy and i've agreed with
that my whole life
but i've been doing things like moving
dirt hauling gravel driving truck
right now i'm way underemployed and i
can't
do anything other than pay my bills
uh but
marketing i i've got a website with my
artwork
nothing has ever happened with it i i
don't know what to do i don't know how
to market my artwork to get people to
see it yeah
tell me about the artwork what kind of
art is it
well it's a wildlife landscape realism
okay uh
forgive me painting i'm assuming
yes painting okay have you ever sold
one painting well did i ever i got a
huge corporation out of chicago they're
the ones that have paid my mortgage uh
they helped me add on 20 years ago
i've been buy or selling to them and
they have given me
like over a hundred thousand dollars in
my life so you were going through a
broker essentially
no no just uh i went to the fairs and i
went to the affairs brought me to
galleries and then the galleries uh i
had customers come in and then uh i had
personal contacts they wanted to meet me
personally and so wait a second wait a
second wait wait wait let me make sure i
hurt you properly
20 plus years ago
you made really good money
selling
the very paintings that right now you're
having a hard time selling and george
just said well what'd you do and you
just list it off you rattled it off so
fast i couldn't write it down
sorry
no no no
ken you've done this before
what am i missing
uh i guess i'll trust that one customer
cannot pay my whole life's income
yeah but yes my point is
ken have you had success selling
paintings that's where i was going i had
no idea you had had that kind of success
i'm blown away so answer the question
have you had success selling paintings
before
nice job uh yes and you had a personal
contact there you go you know what it is
you got to get back out there again i
don't know what the actual fear or doubt
is but that's the issue
the issue is what is the fear
what is the doubt and i mean specific
voice you're wrestling with right now i
want to know because that's what's
holding you back
yeah
that's a that's a good question
that's one i've been asking all my life
yeah but i'm not going to let you off
the hook i'm not going to let you off
the hook because i think you know i want
you to uh
i am i'm trying tell me what are you
most afraid of what do you doubt the
most
yeah that's not going to be uh uh a
steady
stream
okay let's let's now let's dive into
that
okay let's dive into that
maybe it won't be a steady stream at
first
maybe it'll take a few years to get it
to a steady stream maybe that stream
won't be enough to fully take care of
your needs
but is that really the issue because you
can do other work that'll keep you going
you're doing it right now
so what are you really afraid of
you afraid that it was a a whim that it
was a chance that one massive
corporation liked your stuff and they
paid you well for it no one else on the
planet's gonna like your stuff and
because you've done a crappy job of
marketing your art on the web
don't judge yourself by that that's not
how you got success the first time
around feels like to me you gotta dust
off the old plan and that was good
old-fashioned hustle
shoe leather to pavement ken
and you've got a track record i need i
need ideas i guess i i just need ideas
okay you know other than being a blogger
you know i've been going through this
stuff uh it's so much crap on the
internet you try to look up this
information and here's what i want to be
a blogger i know but kim you're you're
still missing it i don't think belonging
is the answer i think you getting back
out and showing your work again
i think for some reason
go ahead
are you saying start over like the art
fairs again yes
yes
who's buying art
where are they
that's where you gotta go you're trying
to do it online
i didn't do very good with the art
periods because i it was marketing i
didn't learn it was like a marketing
lesson to me i came that was four
thousand dollar items at a at a 200 uh
show you know all right i understand but
here's the deal i'm trying to simplify
this for you because i am not an expert
in the art market but what i am good at
doing is simplifying the complex and you
are facing right now what feels like a
very complex problem i'm simplifying it
for you who and you don't have to answer
this right now on the air but this is
your homework assignment who
is buying
four thousand dollar pieces of art who
is buying
four thousand and higher dollar uh
pieces of art that are in your
particular style forgive me if that's
the wrong way to say it but you get my
point
where are they
george you brought up the broker issue
you know who's who's out there
helping sell those things this is good
old-fashioned research there's a market
for it and ken i think the most
important thing is is for you to
remember that you've made a lot of money
selling art before this is not a pipe
dream for you this isn't some
willy-nilly crazy notion
you just gotta get hustling again and be
willing to deal with rejection that's
what's going on george i'm telling you
right now you're gonna hear some no's
but you have to step into those no's
to be able to get some yeses and you're
so worried that you got the only yes
that you could ever get that it's
clouding your judgment yeah there are so
many people out there ken and ken who
who want to buy really great artwork at
that price point so if i'm you i'm gonna
find every avenue and try it and see
what works go to your local coffee shop
and say hey can i hang my painting in
here for free i'll let you guys have it
in here for free if you'll just put my
information underneath it hey i'm gonna
go on tik tok and show people the behind
the scenes of how i do my artwork and
get people excited about it and show
them how much work i put into this
maybe you start on instagram and try
there because that's a great visual
social media place where people are
already hanging out and you start using
some hashtags there are so many avenues
to learn about marketing through youtube
linkedin wherever where you can really
start to test out where are these people
at who really appreciate what i do how
about walking into a local art gallery
talking to the owner and going hey
here's my background 20 years ago i did
this many pieces of art for this company
that's impressive that's credible
and you go hey can i show you a couple
of pieces i got it in the truck and i'm
i'm just i want to start putting my
stuff back out what kind of deal do you
want if you sell it what do you want for
it the answer is whatever whatever they
say say yes you got to start showing
your work and get it back out there
again but i can tell you right now that
the fear of rejection
and the fear of failure
are hanging out on both of ken's
shoulders right now yeah and it has
clouded his
ability to see
that he was successful before he could
be successful he thought it was well it
was my one i did it back then i'll never
do it again it was a stroke of luck yeah
you know i've heard dave say this before
uh that you know making the second
million is easier
there's a reason for that you got some
history
inside of that history are is some skill
inside of that history is some
experience
and um when we embrace that and go wait
i've done this before i'm not starting
from scratch it's not this new thing i
know i can do this then all of a sudden
confidence emerges and i think ken the
name of your game is confidence you got
to get your confidence back up put
yourself out there it's worth it because
i'm going to tell you right now if you
don't do this second time around you're
going to get to the end of your journey
and be sick with regret
don't
regret
reminisce go after it put your work out
there you got this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague
george campbell we're taking your calls
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we're now gonna go to victorville
california where i see on the screen
stefan and lisa are on the line george
and i'm told you guys are on the line to
do a debt-free scream
yes yes oh that's awesome well welcome
thank you so much you bet all right
let's get to the story how much debt did
you pay off
we paid off over 124 thousand dollars
wow
hundred twenty four thousand dollars
okay and uh how long did it take
that took four years of really just
hitting it every single paycheck oh yeah
that's a lot of money that's
unbelievable tell us your range of
income during that time
we from that time that we started we
were about a hundred and fifty thousand
and then um ended up at about two
hundred and fifty thousand whoa
okay we can't go any further i got to
know what led to the hundred thousand
dollars in increase
uh my wife got a promotion to be a
principal so oh nice very nice by the
way i like what happened there george
you know selise was like i'm gonna let
you tell him yep way to go lisa how does
that feel
oh it felt good thank you
that's impressive uh all right so
uh tell us what this debt was what made
up this 124 thousand dollars
that was student loans
that i had accrued you know bachelor's
degree master's degree
my phd
i just kind of wrapped it up okay all
right very good and then we had a car
loan as well that we were able to pay
off all right okay so pretty normal
stuff there so
take us to four years ago when you guys
start this journey what led to this
i think we had done the financial peace
university earth early in our marriage
and so we knew the
the steps and we knew what we needed to
do to make it happen
okay and so what was that you kind of
knew but was there a moment where he
went we've had enough i mean what led to
this because this is we're talking about
intense 124 thousand dollars over four
years
i think finally we've seen that uh
the student loan was actually due
so it made like an impetus that we had
to start really attacking it
so i made it our number one goal was to
pay as much as possible every month
and just attack it you know
so you got sick of giving a chunk of
money away every month and you went we
don't need to do this anymore we make
good money we want to live life on our
terms and have this money back in our
life attacking our goals
exactly i love it so what what did you
guys actually do what were the
sacrifices you made along the way
the sacrifices were things like
cutting back on the big vacations and
thinking about refinancing
where we could with our mortgage and
getting better rates there so that we
would have a better
monthly mortgage payment and just you
know following the the gazelle intensity
of paying it down and communicating and
knowing that this was our
our combined goal to get this out of the
way wow so you reallocated a lot of this
money that could have gone to a lot of
places and you said nope it's got an
assignment it's going to this debt
what was uh is there something that
sticks out to you all as maybe one of
the toughest things you had to deal with
it was really really tough maybe maybe
it was along the way and you felt like
oh we're hitting a lull well what was a
real challenge for you on this journey
i think in the middle it just got kind
of
hard because you know you didn't see
that much of an improvement this you
still uh that insurmountable
mountain you're climbing but then you
just have to keep you know put your head
down and just keep moving and trust the
process
so what was the what do you think the
key was the last the last loan for
another couple out there who may be
where you guys are at
six figures in debt going well we're
just going to pay this thing off for 20
years what would you tell that couple
to getting out of debt
right absolutely
what was the key
the key was just trying to
do right living like no one else so that
we could live like no one else
so you had to change your mindset and go
we've got to live differently rightly so
we can live differently later
so who are your biggest cheerleaders on
this journey walking you through this
like that middle period stefan that you
just mentioned that was so difficult we
didn't feel like you were making so much
progress who helped keep you in the game
i think we
could say our church family that you
know
started us on fpu so many years ago and
then
um we were leaders at one point and just
being that example too you know we
we can talk it but we had to live it as
well
walk the talk yeah that's been a theme
this year yeah really has definitely so
uh
george asked you kind of what the key is
but as you guys sit here today you're
about ready to do this stream how would
you encourage
um others that are listening because at
some point you all listen to other
people do what you're about to do what
would you say to them if they feel like
they're in this lull or they don't know
if they can do it what's your advice to
them
um just keep keep grinding i mean i mean
it looks insurmountable but you know one
step at a time and you'll get through it
and find that the extra side things that
you can contribute to make it a little
bit easier like stefan said it's in the
middle it's still monotonous and you're
looking at the shiny things that you
could be spending your money on
and you have to just
deflect to what you know would be the
right choice
yeah wow well let me tell you something
you all um you're an inspiration you're
heroes
you've done something that is very very
difficult to do you've shared that story
and you stuck together and now you're on
the other side of it what does it feel
like
such a relief such a relief absolutely
yeah you've heard dave talk about the
grass feeling different is that true
what feels different specifically as you
guys walk through your everyday life
i think not having to worry about
extra debt extra payments we have to
make you know now it's
savings and different other projects we
can do and we can save for that
yeah that's awesome and uh i see a
picture here uh two kiddos tell us about
the kids and and and their ages because
we know they're gonna benefit from this
unbelievable sacrifice that you've made
absolutely we have ryan our son he's now
seven and elizabeth is now four and
they're learning the the system they
know that if they don't have the cash
we're not going to give them a card
wow they should run for congress oh
great that'd be great very nice george
very nice that's impressive i like that
changing the family tree hey uh steph
and alyssa we want to gift you with two
books uh to uh thank you for sharing
your story but also for you all
to keep moving forward the first is uh
dave's book the legacy journey because
that really is the next step for you all
on your journey you really are living
and giving like no one else the second
is we want to give you a copy of dave's
wildly popular best-selling book total
money makeover and that is a gift for
you all to give to somebody else
who you can now say hey this works and
we want you to be able to pay that
forward in their life as well so we want
to give you those uh so yes so we'll
send those out to you all right let's do
this
stefan and lisa from victorville
california they paid off 124
000
in four years making 150 000 then up to
250
000
stefan and lisa take it away let's hear
your debt free screen
three two one we're dead free
there it is
another couple
debt-free another student loan bites the
dust there it is
a whole bunch of it too yeah i mean that
was a big big chunk of what they paid
off that's a chunk of the one point now
six trillion dollars sitting out there
oh man
man oh man and uh you know it's great
when you hear the stories but you
realize there's kids involved yeah you
know and and these kids are learning
to not ever fall into that same trap
their mom and dad did but you think
about the life that those kids are gonna
lead as a result of what their mom and
dad did i mean this really is legacy and
i love that we give him a copy of the
legacy journey because that's what this
whole thing is about george yeah they've
you've got to teach these kids this
stuff early on and these kids caught it
it wasn't just todd they saw mom and dad
sacrifice along the way and i doubt
they're ever going to touch dead after
hearing this story
amazing stuff amazing stuff thank you
again stephan and lisa you are heroes
thank you for sharing your story
countless people will be inspired to do
what you did so thank you again very
much he is george campbell i'm ken
coleman you're listening to the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show uh
if you've been paying attention to any
news
you've probably heard the term the great
resignation flying around
and uh it's the big name that people are
kind of putting on this massive job
turnover situation going on uh in this
country
people are saying hey um
i don't like where i am i want to level
up i want more out of my work and so
they're leaving looking for something
better now you may feel like now is the
right time for you as well but if you
don't have a clue what you actually want
to do then you may not even actually get
what you want and move to something
that's going to be better for you in the
long term you need a plan
and you're right
work isn't supposed to be a four letter
word you can find work that will leave
you feeling energized and fulfilled you
can make the income and the impact you
want out of the same gig and that's why
i wrote my brand new book
that reveals to you the clear path to
finding and doing work you love from
paycheck to purpose we'll walk you
through the proven plan that has helped
thousands of people find their dream job
and when you pre-order the book today
we'll also send you over 100 in free
bonus tools like resume templates guides
a video course on how to get hired and
beat the competition all of that is
going to add value to you on this
journey so get your copy of from
paycheck to purpose today
at
ramseysolutions.com that's
ramseysolutions.com the book is from
paycheck to purpose
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number let's go to azure in
dallas texas how can we help
hi it's wonderful to talk to you thank
you um i
i had a small counseling practice up in
north texas and i am looking to relocate
to east texas in about a year and a half
um and i'm trying to figure out what's
the best way to transfer it do i sell it
and re and just restart or
move it down there
yeah that's that's a very interesting
question my question is is have you
looked into
what the details could look like if you
were to sell the practice meaning
is there any interest uh who would you
approach to see if there is interest
where are you on that option
sure so i have two two other therapists
that have contracted with me they work
underneath me and one of them is a good
possibility of possibly wanting to
purchase it
and she's she's up and coming and she's
dynamite so she would be a good option
but i don't know that she would
definitely be able to do it in a year
and a half yeah yeah well and so when
you talk about counseling practice i
mean
are you doing much um i don't want to
call it telecounseling but i mean are
you doing much zoom stuff or is now
everything kind of resumed back to in
person for you
i do a lot of both actually um and it's
been a really good option and having the
zoom option has been a really great deal
for my clients um i probably care about
20 of my clients online and the other
the other 80 are in person yeah i'm
going to throw another option at you i'm
sure you've thought of it but i just i'm
curious
why wouldn't you if you're just simply
moving from one part of texas to the
other
and you already are doing 20 of your
counseling online if you will
why wouldn't you keep the practice
uh where it is and just open up another
office where you are
i have considered that and
my concern is
that i wouldn't have
enough of the client base to to get the
revenue that i need to to maintain and
to pay for another office space
um if that makes sense like in the
interim until i build up another
another client base in the new location
would it be enough but yes and i have i
have thought about you know continuing
with some of my current clients online i
just know that um the majority of them
don't want to do online and they
probably would fall off if i you know if
i moved okay
and i get that
yeah but see here's the issue when
you're selling a counseling business
what are you really selling
you know i'm guessing you don't own your
building is that fair
that's true i rent office bills yeah so
what are you selling
in your mind i want you to answer that
so i incorporated i have a pllc
and i have the i have software that is
set up specifically for this practice
okay people know they know where it is
and they're familiar with the kit with
the name of the practice
but it's it's primarily north texas
nobody any section
right exactly so my point is is if you
move to a different part of texas and
only 20 of your clients want to continue
to do online that means 80 percent of
your clientele has to choose are they
going to keep coming to this practice
even though they're not seeing you
they're not gonna have to choose to see
the other two counselors correct
that's correct yeah so i guess my point
is you've got a challenge in that the
person who's interested in buying it
isn't going to be able to buy it when
you want to move
and so i think in this situation i would
probably if you can't get somebody else
to buy that software
and then
i mean what else are they buying i just
think it's a hard purchase to sell i
think it's a hard sell and so i think i
would just wrap it up and uh and i would
move on that's what i would do but if
you could sell it great sell it but i
think that's going to be difficult so i
think that you may just end up having to
shut it down and then reopen where you
move
that makes good sense i appreciate the
insight yeah yeah you bet thanks for the
call and you know george it's very
interesting in this world we live in now
you know
because of the quality of video
conferencing
um you know doctors were doing
telemedicine that way certainly i think
uh counseling is a very intimate setting
um but it is it is possible to do that
kind of work now yeah that way if you
can do it if you can get clients to do
it i like the idea of her not letting go
of this quite yet and starting small in
her new area yeah and starting to build
that up over time and maybe by then
there's a buyer or one of her counselors
are able to purchase it yeah absolutely
uh let's go to mitchell now in
chattanooga tennessee not too far from
us here in the nashville area mitchell
how can we help
hey thanks for taking my call so um a
few months back i used kent's principles
and got a new career and that got me out
of debt oh i like there we go
yeah so now i can actually start um
contributing to the company match 401k
since i've out of baby step three
and they have a six percent match so my
question is with dave's 15 going into
retirement would i do six percent match
and then nine percent outside of that or
six percent there and then 15 outside of
that that's a great question and in
these instances when you've got a
company match we look at that as icing
on the cake so i still want you
investing 15
of your income into that 401k and if
there's a roth option that's even better
and then take that six percent match as
a bonus but no it's not going to be a
six and a nine on your part i want you
to invest still the full 15 your job
could change your life could change the
company numbers could change the
benefits could change but i want you
consistently investing 15 percent
okay and would i do the 15 in the
company match on top of the six or would
i go through an elp and just do it
separately from the company match no
they have a 401k correct
yes yes yeah so what you want to do
there is you'd go up to the match that's
six percent then you can open up a roth
ira if you don't have one already and
you can work with a smartvestor pro like
you mentioned there to uh get that open
and you want to max that out uh the
limit is 6000 for most people this year
and then you go back to the 401k
uh and you can dump money into there and
if it's that's if it's not a roth option
i assume it's there is no roth option
there
no it's it's the uh target date option
as far as i know it's a traditional 401k
okay if it's traditional then that's
what you do is go to the roth then back
to the 401k and finish out your 15
percent
awesome okay thanks you guys thanks so
much yeah absolutely congratulations uh
what a success story i love it guys got
him a new career but by the way that's
the bigger shovel yeah right there if if
we can help eat ramsey solutions uh
through through the ken coleman show and
the resources we've created to get that
bigger shovel
uh let's go because that's an example
mitchell got a better gig got promoted
and got out of debt and now he's calling
you for investing questions i mean this
is what it's about
this is the sweet spot when it comes to
what we do here ken is when you can
intertwine the career side the purpose
side with the money side and you realize
they actually work hand in hand they do
i mean have you ever heard a debt free
scream i've not have you ever heard one
where they didn't make at least some
more money i mean just some not many
times it's substantial where they make
more money yeah so making more money is
a big part of getting out of debt george
and i will take those calls i'd love to
hear it
i want to thank our producer james
childs our associate producer and call
screener kelly i want to thank you
george thanks for hanging with me we
want to thank you america for listening
because we do it for you this is your
show
it is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting for the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show and it's where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
your money your work i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague george campbell
the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five okay so george i gotta get
you to weigh in okay on something i saw
in the news i don't weigh much but i'll
try it
well
it's well played sir okay so here's the
headline i believe this is wall street
journal yeah
uh
millennials
team up
to fulfill the dream of home ownership
burdened by debt and facing soaring home
prices first-time home buyers are
pooling their finances with partners
friends or roommates
what
george this is frightening say it isn't
so
it is so wall street journal is pretty
reputable yeah here's the thing it says
the number of co-buyers with different
last names increased by 771 percent
between 2014 and 2021. so this isn't
just a 2021 phenomenon
this is kind of happening and what's
happening is uh millennials are strapped
with student loan payments and all kinds
of other payments and they can't afford
home ownership and they're going to
inflation and i live in a high cost of
living area and so what do you do ken
you call up your buddy and say hey rent
is real expensive what if we went in on
this and we became homeowners together
okay now let's talk about the nuances
there
it's not a it's not a spousal situation
where you both have the same last name
no and as we teach shared assets and all
that stuff shared bank accounts these
are two completely different individuals
so uh two of my favorite
fake names to use in these scenarios is
bob and larry so let's say
sandwich by the way would do this no
millennials on the planet are named bob
and larry parents don't name their kids
that anymore they don't be robert okay
so let's go with
let's go with robert and uh
randolph perfect and robert and randolph
are buddies and they go okay well let's
go do this and so they buy a house
together
what's that look like they're both on
the loan
yes it's called the joint tenancy or
tenancy in common okay and so it's it
happens and it's just two buddies
friends they don't have any marital no a
connection and they just want to own a
home and so you can you legally it's
possible it's not an illegal thing to do
it's totally fine to do but
it's a very dangerous move why is it
dangerous well um home ownership is a
big deal yeah and when you got your name
on the title of that home uh and then
you gotta go okay well who's gonna hire
the handyman who's gonna handle the
mortgage payments uh what if one moves
away what if one gets married and so
what happens is uh there can be a lot of
hairy stuff in that relationship that
goes down yeah i mean you're stuck i
said well robert robert meets a gal
falls i want her to move in you're
getting moved out wait wait wait wait
wait i co-own the house it's just an and
by the way we're at the very top of the
onion here we haven't really peeled it
no there's all kinds of problems here
legal mess
uh relationship mess i mean it's just a
mess but like many things it looks good
on paper and you go well financially
this is a great move when it comes down
to the numbers but when people see this
through these rose-colored glasses and
then life happens it gets real messy and
i think we're going to see a lot of
relationships hurt by this as we try to
figure out all the nuances of
homeownership with someone that you
don't have a real connection with so
the moral of the story is please don't
fall prey to this supposed good idea
this has just got all kinds of crazy
risk attached to it but i mean wow
extreme times it points back to
what we're trying to do with this
borrowed future documentary help people
get rid of their student loans so that
they can live the american dream yeah
buy your own house
yeah i love it home ownership all right
let's get to the phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five abby is
joining us in san francisco california
how can we help
hey ken hey george all right thanks for
taking my call sure
uh yeah so this is kind of based on the
student loan thing that's a little like
you guys are talking about um so my
partner took out loans to go to college
and her parents took out 175 000 parent
plus loans
so if we get made like combined we'll be
making a total of 240 000 a year so
i just wanted to press this by saying i
don't have a problem combining finances
paying it fully off when you get married
even though it's very false i get that
currently her parents are on
income-based repayment and they're
hoping for loan forgiveness in ten years
as their mom is a teacher but like
george already talks about everywhere
forgiveness chances about like two
percent so like what kind of
conversation should i have about
boundaries with my partner and their
parents like before we get married
you are a wise man abby for even having
this level of maturity to go i've got to
have boundaries i've got to have a hard
conversation and so is this a
conversation that you
and her need to have with her parents or
is this how do i have the conversation
with her
both i guess
i just i'm just lost as to how to have
this conversation because her parents
have made it clear that
they want to hope for forgiveness in ten
years but it's only two percent chance
like i don't know what to do
yeah
well
you're not going to be able to convince
the in-laws of much that's a difficult
thing to do to give them financial
advice i've tried that it did not go
well so i'm telling you from experience
what you can do is empower your wife and
help her have this conversation with her
parents to say hey listen
we
this was this was loans you took out for
me and we want to do an honorable thing
and pay these off
we don't want you guys to have this on
your shoulders and wait a decade
as we grow into our adult life and still
have these loans hanging around for the
hope of forgiveness which we've seen not
moving at breakneck speeds even with new
legislation and new presidents i just
don't see a day where there were it gets
much better than this and so i think
you're doing the wise thing by having
the conversation but i think you need to
have it with her and not go directly to
the the in-laws or future in-laws
so then if they want they're older
should they want to retire soon i'm sure
so wanted to come back down onto us
later on anyway like i'm just trying to
understand
you're saying what do you do once you
guys are married what do you do then
financially if you want to pay them off
no not that like if
our parents want to retire right they
can't retire when they have this kind of
loan where they have to pay income based
for payment plans so like how would that
affect us because it will come back down
to on to us
no i mean it's her parents took this out
and so when what happens is when the
student applies for a loan and can't get
it then it turns into the parent plus
loan if the parent is willing to take it
on solo so normally a parent can cosign
for the loan meaning hey you're both on
the hook and if if abi doesn't pay then
it goes to the parent but in this case
the parent is fully on the hook and so
that's the scary part with these parent
plus loans is the parents are trying to
do the best thing for their kid and set
them up but then they can't retire and
so what happens is the kids then have to
help the parents in retirement and it
really creates a bad bad situation so
you guys have a fantastic income and i
think it's really honorable that you're
wanting to pay these loans off even
though they're not in her name
and so i think if she has that
conversation maybe you sit down with her
if they're willing to have it together
and you say hey listen here's what we
want to do once we're married we want to
tackle her loans and we really
appreciate what you guys have done to
allow her to go to school but we want to
take these on and help get this thing
out of our lives and we don't want to
wait a decade yeah and again i think
that
having her be the one that cast this
vision because it's her parents yeah and
tied it into their retirement and the
way they want to finish out not from the
son-in-law yeah stay out of it the
parent plus loans huge high interest
rate i don't want you waiting 10 years
and then nothing happens
and run the numbers show them the
numbers yeah of how it's going to
actually turn out good stuff george
thank you for the call abby all right
don't move folks more of your calls
right around the corner this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
the ramsay show continues
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
none other than george camel and we are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five i gotta tell you
something i've never told you before oh
boy i really enjoy saying your last name
wow that means a lot yeah camel
thank you by the way tell people how
it's spelled if they're new to you it's
with a k k-a-m-e-l like the animal and i
will say ken i do have a middle eastern
background that's a shock to a lot of
people based on my uh complexion
you said that i just came back from cabo
after a week oh you did i don't think
i'm even one percent tanner did you soak
in 75 sunscreen well it was about 100
degrees in full sun i didn't want to
come back crispy you know okay i burn
easily do you tan no so you have a very
light complexion and that's just your
deal and you're going with it that's
just my deal fantastic hey if you aren't
strapped with student loan payments odds
are you know someone who has millions
are putting their lives on hold they
can't buy a house or have kids because
they're stuck or even worse they're
waiting and waiting and waiting
and waiting for the government to save
them with student loan forgiveness which
by the way is a total joke
our team has produced a new documentary
called borrowed future and it's out now
it uncovers the dark side of the student
loan industry and exposes how the system
is built to work against you you'll see
dave ramsey weigh in on the epic failure
otherwise known as the student loan
program along with featured interviews
from industry insiders we're coming at
this crisis hard folks we're taking big
swings at the student loan problem with
the goal to armed parents and students
across the country with the truth which
is you do not have to take out loans to
get a college education you can graduate
debt free and avoid the predatory
student loan industry borrowed future is
available for streaming now go watch on
apple tv amazon prime video google play
or
go to the website borrowed future
dot com that's borrowed future
dot com you're excited about this
because you you kind of were involved in
the precursor yes with the podcast and a
lot of the stories started there and
you'll hear some of that but i'm just so
passionate about this topic as we dug
into it uh this was two years ago and we
just did a bonus episode for the podcast
and uh surprisingly not much has changed
in the student world the student loan
world can in two years forgiveness
hasn't budged much the legislation
hasn't budged much a few of the players
in the game like navient they're getting
out but it still doesn't give me a ton
of hope i still would say stay away
don't recommend 100 because i will tell
you right now i don't mind saying this i
think that whole forgiveness language
and conversation is a carrot
to get more people to jump in well
they're gonna forgive it so this is free
money
and waiting watch this documentary if
you said hey you can have it but you
need to wait 10 years tell that to an 18
year old 22 year old that's a lifetime
yeah it really is so it's a lifetime for
me my goodness oh thank you just not
interested no no no triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
let's go to gainesville georgia
incidentally george where i started my
radio career
was the radio station where i started
out so i love gainesville georgia ashton
joins us there ashton how can we help
hey i just wanted to say first and
foremost i'm a huge fan i've been
listening since i was in high school wow
um and
i've been following uh
for the past five years because i
graduated 2016 has uh
been doing my dave ish
plan and i have recently just
come to realize that
dave ish doesn't work and it's all or
nothing
and um so with that i have a huge
question i'm currently in baby step two
and i'm also
cash flowing my way through school
no student loans or anything but i do
have just shy of 20 grand in debt
um with a household income of right
under 40k i want to say it's like 39.5
is what right about what i bring in what
kind of debt is the 20 grand
so 10 3 of it is a car loan and then the
rest of it is just multiple credit cards
kind of spread out
between different credit cards
and my big question with that is
do i need to put a hold on school to
finish baby step 2
or do i finish cash flowing my way
through
in this degree that i started as uh i'm
not even sure if this is the field i
want to go in or
not i'm not sure so all right so let's
press pause on the on the uh money
question and because i think this is
going to tie in if you're not entirely
sure i want to know which percentage you
would put on it right now is it 50 50 is
it 80 20 70 30 as to
how sure you are that this degree you're
in right now is not the direction you
want to go
hit me straight as far as
as far as
it's a business management degree that
i'm working on right now
and as far as percentage wise and
everything like that goes i'm looking at
like i'm like
70 30
70 30 not pursuing that direction
the 30 would be in the knot the 70 is in
the end uh as far as pursuing and so
he's leaning towards a yes oh you're
okay i i confused myself here you are
leaning towards moving into business
management type work
correct it's really just a
with how broad of an umbrella the degree
is and everything like that i'm not sure
where specifically and there i want to
go i do have about a about 14 months
yeah of management experience that shift
leading count
hey ashton i gotta tell you right now i
would press pause on cash flowing to
school and i'd crush the deck because
i'm gonna tell you right now
you don't need a degree to get into
business management you already said you
got 14 months of experience leading
you know
you could go get a job two jobs increase
your income which gets you out of debt
faster and get in a situation where
you're following somebody and there's an
opportunity there's a ladder there for
you to step up into leadership you don't
need a degree to get into leadership
so i would press pause there's just too
much unknowns right now for you to be
taking that valuable cash
and cash flowing a super general degree
for sure the only reason that i uh that
i have that experience i've been working
in the food business for a while um and
everything and i uh my fiance and i
welcomed our son into the world back in
2019
and i
jumped up uh you know jumped up the
chain just a little bit just to bring in
a little extra money but that
jump forward put me in a bind on the
family end
and every schedule
it felt like it drove a wedge
into that and everything and so it was
like it was like i was doing my calling
but in the wrong
area and i don't know quite where that
area okay we're gonna lock in we're
gonna lock in right here ashton you just
led to it
you felt like you were doing your
calling but in the wrong place i like to
call that you're doing the right thing
in the wrong place i'm guessing the
hours in the food service industry and
all that was just crushing the
relationship i get that uh because you
got a little one now
so is leading and managing people that's
what you love to do
that yes okay so so hold on how are you
thinking from
hold on i want you to focus on something
very clearly
if you can lead people and manage people
and develop people help them win in the
food industry can you not do the same
thing in other industries
yes or no for sure
for sure i like that answer george
confident all right so george let's now
so here's the deal ash i'm gonna turn
you over to george i want you to press
pause on this degree right now i'm not
saying don't go back and finish it but
i'm saying you can move up
professionally even now
because you've got leadership experience
he's got 20 grand to pay off george yeah
at this point is your fiance working
she is
in about 1400 a month 1400 a month and
that's on top of the 40 that you're
bringing in a year
correct okay well if either of you can
get a second job i want to tackle this
thing if you're going to pause school
then we need to go really hard at this
debt if you were going to continue
school i'd say all right well continue
through school cash flow that and then
tackle this debt as soon as you graduate
but if we're pausing school we've got to
get got to get rid of this debt i mean
this is half of your income tied up and
credit cards and car loans maybe see how
much the car is worth you can drive a
beater for a while and get this debt uh
payoff cut in half i'm all for that and
here's the deal they're gonna knock out
the 20 grand pretty quick school will
still be there okay but this is the
greatest priority and i think it's going
to put some attention on how i can get
where i want to get
minus the degree and leading people
well you don't have to have a degree to
lead people come on get after it young
man your future is waiting for you don't
move he is george campbell i'm ken
coleman you're listening to the ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
the ramsay show continues i'm kid
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell and we're taking your calls
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five how many of you out
there want to get a bigger shovel so you
can fast forward the process of getting
out of debt we can help with that that
is
a particular area of focus for me george
and i will team up on those uh if you're
feeling like hey i'm just not doing work
that i enjoy at all
we're taking those calls of course
that's what i do on the ken coleman show
and then george is going to answer your
money questions he's ready to go as
always and
we love doing this we are here because
we really enjoy coaching you up so
let's go triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five and in
the lobby
of ramsay solutions on the debt-free
stage i see
jason and stacey
how are you
good how are you you guys are here to do
a debt-free scream yes i love it where
are you guys from booneville indiana
okay very nice all right tell us give us
the numbers how much did you pay off
we paid off 68 000
how long about three years and five
months three years five months and what
was your range of income
98 000 to about 110. 98 to 110 what do
you guys do
i'm a service man for water utility okay
great and i'm a third grade public
school teacher oh okay very nice but you
have to have a lot of energy don't you
to keep up with third graders for sure
i love it okay so what kind of debt was
the 68 000
we were super normal we had credit cards
student loans truck payment car payment
401 401k loan medical bills just a
little bit of everything i think so
george did she leave anything out that
was like the potpourri of debt right
there very impressive that is awesome i
love it so what happened three years ago
where you guys said now not doing this
anymore we're getting debt free
well i had had a really long day at
school one day and i needed to stop at
target and get some things for school
the next day for a science experiment
and i just blindly grabbed some things
and i went through the checkout and my
debit card was declined and i wasn't
even mad of course i didn't think it was
my fault i thought there's something
wrong with this machine
and i just used my credit card and went
to my car and i thought you know i'm
going to pull up our accounts just to be
sure that everything's fine and all i
saw was red like everything was negative
he had no clue i had no clue
and what really just got me was that we
were in a normal time we hadn't had any
extra expenses or anything come up and i
just had no clue and i thought we are
too far along in our career and we work
way too hard for us to have no money
where is all of our money going and so i
just said we have got to do something
different wow
so jason what'd she say to you and how
did you respond
i don't even remember what it was
but uh you know it was basically we have
no money yeah and what do you say do
something
yes
yeah and then and so at what point uh do
you introduce
the financial peace university the
ramsey solution stuff and what was the
was it fpu was it the total money
makeover what what was the uh the
starting point well what's funny is i
owned the total money makeover but i
never read it
i've read it multiple times since yeah
um but a couple of our really good
friends had the home study kit for fpu
and had offered it to us and so when i
got home that night i texted her and i
said please bring me this kit we are
ready and i we started the next night
okay and and i'm i'm reading by the body
language here jason that you were all in
you weren't pushing back you were like
oh no yeah if we're gonna do it we're
gonna do it that's amazing
what's that what's that feel like each
of you comment on that when each of the
spouse you realize hey we're not
fighting against each other on this
we're joining arms here oh that's a
great feeling
yeah it made all the difference really
because i was i was so upset with myself
and i feel like he easily could have
been upset with me for for having this
hole that he really didn't even know
about um but he definitely showed a lot
of grace and he he kind of owned his
part of you know he kind of never paid
attention to our finances and so when i
came to him and i said i've been doing
this on my own for a really long time
but obviously i'm not very good at it
and we need to do this together and and
he agreed and he said you're right so
you would you guys went from problem
unaware you didn't even know you were
broke to solution focus real quick you
went zero to sixty three years five
months ago what made you guys just go
all right game on nothing's stopping us
um i think when we well people look at
us and have told us before you know you
don't really seem like the kind of
people that are in debt
and and we didn't think we were either
we're not fancy people i mean at all and
so but when you list out your debt
um
one of my favorite podcasters says you
gotta know where your fist is gonna land
when you're punching it in the face and
that's true when you list out all your
debt and we totaled 68 thousand dollars
i mean we were blown away and so we knew
we had to get serious wow
unbelievable so what did you actually do
what were the tactical sacrifices you
made to get rid of this debt in three
years and five months
basically nothing extra nothing no
frills yeah none at all we did so much
budgeting and
i became really good at
meal planning and freezer meal cooking
and we we cut out all the fat all the
subscriptions the pandemic helped you
know nobody did anything we didn't go
anywhere we both were very fortunate to
have jobs that were very secure you know
all through that time and so we just
used that time to kind of to kind of
keep us rolling forward and um we just
locked arms and put our head down and
said we're getting this done what kind
of what kind of meals are we talking
about did we have a lot of rice and
beans or did you get a little bit uh
yeah we had a little bit of chicken and
pork and
he's willing to sacrifice but he's not
going vegan yeah right
and potatoes yeah yeah yeah that's
that's a sturdy man over there he's not
going to go vegan
yeah you guys got a raise along the way
what happened there with the increase
well um
as a teacher i don't get many races
right you know he does and then i also
just side hustled like crazy
tutoring summer school i sell avon pet
sitting dog sitting house sitting we
just anything we could what was the most
lucrative side gig
um i think teaching summer school
actually there's not a lot of things
that teachers can do for their hourly
rate but summer school is one of them
and so it's a lot of hard work it's
intense it's a short amount of time
um but it was it was good money for what
for the work so gave up a summer that's
that's two summers actually two wow
god bless our teachers yeah absolutely
well you guys have done it so what would
you say is the key to making it through
this journey
well
just helping each other
being there and being willing to work
together
i listen to that question asked a lot
because i listen to the podcast all the
time and i always agree with everything
that everyone says and i would add to
that consistency you know it's not just
about
um
budgeting or
communication for one month or for three
months or for six months it's about the
consistency for month after month year
after year we still create a unique
monthly written budget every single
month we just have a different
relationship with money now and so it
just takes that consistency and if we
can do it anyone can do it we were team
tiny shovel and we did it so anyone can
do it you did it and uh did you bring
someone with you today we do what do we
have we brought our son wyatt he does
not really want to come up he doesn't
have to he'll be 14 next week
you just explained everything yeah i i
totally now get it my kids only want to
be seen in the same zip code with me
much less a stage so i get that well hey
real quick before you do your screen we
want to give you two things one the copy
of dave's
latest book the legacy journey that's
the next stage for use you guys really
build legacy um and so we want to give
that to you and also a copy of the total
money makeover for you to gift to
somebody else so we want to give you
that uh as a gift and appreciation for
sharing your story all right here we go
you guys ready to roll okay we've got
jason and stacy from evansville indiana
area they paid off 68 thousand dollars
in three years and five months making 98
thousand to a hundred and ten thousand
dollars jason and stacy take it away
let's hear your debt-free scream
three three two
one we're debt-free
yes you are
uh you know kind of strategy their
journey teachers are great communicators
nothing less they are you know what i
love about this particular story because
you know obviously we have a lot of
couples we go i love that like their
story was they both realized at the same
time had no clue but both also decided
come on let's go yes there wasn't any
hanging on any arguing and he was like
no let's go dude it tells me there was a
healthy marriage there to start very
healthy and even healthier now that is
really awesome stuff wow that's why we
do we do george i love it never gets old
no it does not
tell you what else doesn't get old
the show the ramsay show don't move
we're coming right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show
where we hope you get where you want to
go in your money
in your
work
in your relationships we're helping you
live the life that you want through
practical
steps
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number i'm ken coleman and
i'm joined
this hour by my colleague george
campbell we're thrilled that you have
joined us blinds.com
uh
blinds.com that was i don't know why i
struggled to say that george 100
satisfaction guarantee means that even
if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color which i would mismeasure george
that's a type two you you and me no chip
gains yeah exactly so this is why
blinds.com blinds.com rather is where
you want to go they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month
you'll save even more make sure you use
the promo code ramsay to get the best
deal today's question comes from jessa
in michigan i am a loan officer at a
credit union and i absolutely love my
job but i also am on the dave ramsey
plan and have i have fell in love with
teaching your concept to our members
about getting out of debt i feel like a
hypocrite because basically my job
involves me creating debt do you have
any advice for us who are stuck in
corporate america i feel like i am not
part of the solution to money issues but
have become part of the problem what
fields can i pursue so i can become a
solution
well it sounds to me like jessa really
enjoys the financial industry yeah and
so she's she's obviously because she
believes in what we teach at ramsey
solution there is a conflict there now
first we start with jessa
you aren't part of the problem you
aren't a bad person you are not doing
anything that's unethical
or illegal however i understand that the
values disconnect so if you love
finances
the planning the strategy the numbers
and all that kind of stuff and you want
to help people win financially that
doesn't involve debt i'm still looking
at uh
one of our smart investor pros you know
you know our system i really want you to
to reach out to somebody uh in our in
your area that's a smart investor pro
and go hey ken coleman i was the ramsey
show they read my thing and told me to
call you guys i think about moving into
your side of things because i want to
help people win with money not get
weighed down with money and i think
coffee lunch a phone call
to learn a little bit more about the
investment side of things financial
planning certainly financial coaching is
an option
working for an organization that
has good products and services that
better people's lives and maybe you work
in the finance side of that company what
i'm trying to say here is there's a
whole lot of opportunities for you you
don't have to feel as though you are
painted in the credit union corner you
can do a lot of what you like to do in a
lot of different places and she's saying
she's a loan officer and she loves her
job and if you do that i mean we have
our friends at churchill mortgage
they're helping people get mortgages the
right way that's right so i think it's a
great opportunity if you work for you
maybe you are a mortgage loan officer
you help people understand the right way
to get into a house that isn't going to
bury them and so you go hey i want you
to do this there's a great way to do
this here's the kind of down payment
here's what kind of mortgage loan i
would steer you to and here's why to
where she can actually help people
that's right do it the ramsey way and do
it uh financially that's a very good
point george she may be able to stay in
the credit union if it's a perspective
change don't
push somebody to a bad product but if
you're getting pressure to push to a bad
product then if she's making car loans
all day i get it yeah but if you want if
you love the loan industry i think
mortgages might be something that she
could get into where she could really
help people yeah and really guide people
to do it the right way really good stuff
there all right let's get back to the
phones triple eight eight two five five
two two five robert joins us in
albuquerque new mexico robert how can we
help
how are you doing
well we're having a blast what's going
on
every day is a good day um i just had a
question i have uh you well i work now i
make good money
and me and my wife are you know pretty
much
debt well not pretty much we're
debt-free except for our mortgage okay
and
uh the problem is is the company i'm
working for
basically
you know got rid of all the people that
started the company
and then now the new owner
is
wanting me
because i'm outside south
wanting me to do like things that i
don't agree with that to me you know
belgium gouge our customers and i don't
agree with it okay so they got rid of
everyone else and those people are
starting a new company and they want me
to go there well i'm leaving a
six bigger job
to go there and then start over
but i don't know if you know my wife
thinks that that you know she doesn't
know if it's a good idea or not but
morally i can't
i just i can't do it right well so i'm
not into that that's not because i'm in
construction
just to kind of give you a little yeah
well you're a good man robert you're a
good man and um
you've got a decision before you one way
or the other so you and your wife got to
sit down and go okay one way or the
other i can't keep doing this
i think the million-dollar question for
you robert is how much longer can you do
it are you at a point where you feel
like
day that you stay here
and you're asked to do something you
don't agree with it's like could you
last 30 days doing this i don't think
the answer is yes but i want to know
what you how long can you last until you
find something else to step into if we
don't take this startup opportunity
i want to leave it today can you do that
financially
i did i have a lot of regular
customers that you know i'm charging
them double what i did before right and
it's just not right okay so they're just
making more money right so but
financially you can't walk today did i
hear you say that
yeah i mean
now i mean my wife makes good money too
so i think you could you don't have any
debt you're only dead we have six months
of our reserve yeah well i don't want
you i don't want you to necessarily use
that my question is can you live off of
your wife's salary for 30 days 60 days
not okay so here's the deal you're going
to have to you got to be a big boy you
got to be grown up here and so i think
it comes down to doing your homework and
finding out what would you make
is it straight commission if you go with
the startup all these people you used to
work with
yes okay
so
you one way or the other it's like you
can't be without pay for 30 day uh well
for 60. i think you could do 30 is what
it sounds like to me so you're gonna
have to bite your lip and you're not
doing anything unethical you may not
like the way it feels but until you can
find something to replace what you're
doing and you should be able to as good
of a salesman as you are you shouldn't
be able to do it or the other question
is is how quickly talk to these guys
that want you go hey let's be realistic
guys
i i can't go 60 days without making
money how quickly am i going to be able
to get up and running and actually sell
some stuff have you had that
conversation
we've had that conversation but at the
same time i've already got
you know at least 10 to 15 customers
that said they'll go wherever i go oh
well you didn't tell me that that's
different okay i know absolutely i'm
getting into it okay no no no i'm not
getting on you i'm just going that's
again that's different information
um i'd go tomorrow if the 10 to 15 are
going to follow you i'd go tomorrow
because now you can sleep it well at
night you can live with yourself and
that's more than enough customers to get
you going
right
oh absolutely yes well then it's a
no-brainer it's just my wife is not all
for it what would you how do you
convince me is it because of the income
from a six-figure
salary to
you know
you don't think you can get back to six
figures in no time
i think so well you got to show her that
robert this this is a safety issue
your wife doesn't feel safe
you've got to show her how i know i know
but listen but the good that's good news
and bad news bad news is your wife
doesn't feel safe the good news is all
you have to address is our safety so you
got to sit down with her with a good
old-fashioned piece of paper and pencil
and go with the 10 to 15 go with me over
here this is where i'm realistically
going to be in the first three to six
months it's going gonna pinch us maybe a
little bit but we're in no way we're no
way near any kind of danger and you show
her how long it's gonna take to get
where it's going and you have a
conversation where she goes oh okay i
feel safe and a reminder we've got six
months in our emergency fund yeah we
have no consumer debt you're positioned
we can do this
you absolutely can do this
uh yeah i would do that tomorrow like
i'd do it today end of business
if i talk to my wife first i want the
wife to feel safe sorry smart man i did
get a little excited about like married
ken 23 years which is why men did what i
said there talk to the wife then submit
the resignation that's the order of that
hey uh good stuff george thanks man
always fun i want to thank our producer
james childs and our associate producer
and call screener kelly daniel and we
want to thank you america this is your
show it is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life
your money your work your relationships
it's all on the table we want to help
you
and the way we do it is just good
old-fashioned conversation coaching you
up giving you some practical steps to
take that you can do because it is up to
you and i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague uh fellow ramsey personality
george campbell with a k by the way
k-a-m-e-l thank you for that ken yeah
can i just say i always appreciate when
you call me a colleague it just feels i
feel very
my back straightens up yeah i've better
posture you know why that is why is that
because you're a millennial
i'm an exer and i think colleague is a
term that you are only vaguely familiar
with so when i say it it has a little
extra punch to it although it just means
co-worker it feels old-timey in a good
way it is i'm a little bit of an old
soul kelly's looking at me like she's
irritated should i should i retire
colleague
no boy oh she's oh you're irritated at
george thank you very much okay because
i feel
colleagues at a millennial this is too
two
like
classic guys
yes yes and kelly and i are almost like
exactly the same age i would have
thought kelly was much younger
way younger nice move george
well-played i'm mostly just scared of
kelly so just trying to earn the brownie
points where i can as you should all
right let's get to the phones
hazard kentucky oh that's cool
josh is on the line and has well i love
saying this and hazard josh is there
josh how can we help
yes i'm actually currently in baby step
two uh me and my wife we make around
eighty thousand dollars a year
right before i started the baby steps we
bought a uh property which was adjoining
a uh
development area which was of entry
tourism in myriad where really it's a
rural area
long story short it took off
very well this and the county government
has actually got a grant for their side
of the adventure terrorism for like 1.5
million and they're making a lodge and
right now like i said i'm on baby step
two we're working the plan
uh we're just kind of my first cabin i
built i ended up doing some rentals
there
uh kind of want to see where i need to
go if it should be right to build
another cabin now or wait till we get
finished the bank has actually i spoke
with them they're open with doing
another one but i understand you know
it's hard to get out of a
hole with a very small shovel at the
same time if you're digging deeper so so
you are taking out loans to build these
cabins
yes it was before we started any type of
baby steps or anything and you're saying
hey should i go build another cabin if
it's going to mean taking out another
loan yes that's the only thing i don't
really want to go through with that but
at the same time like i've turned away
like 30 people the last month for
bookings on my cabin
so you're seeing the dollar signs going
man i got to get another cabin asap i
can make some money yeah
how much debt do you have
uh minus my mortgage and the vacation
rental i've got about forty thousand
forty consumer event
yeah it's a couple cars and then a
personal loan and one credit card
okay
and what uh do you have any business
debt
uh yes for the land the property we
bought in the cabin it was the
we owed about 50 58 000 i think on that
how much
about 80 how much are you clearing josh
on this one cabin rental that's just hot
hot hot
um i'm clearing uh a wrap thousand
dollars a month on it so
yeah unless they're there yeah but i
mean you haven't gotten into any repairs
that thousand dollars a month that's not
a whole lot when you think about upkeep
and stuff like that that's 12 grand a
year so it's not a it's not a money
making scheme
yeah so the answer is no you're not
going to go into debt for another one
you're not even making enough money to
get that excited i mean i understand
it's kind of nice to see it all booking
up and stuff like that but the reality
is you're clearing
right now and what i ask you clearly i
mean are you working in expenses to that
like upkeep and repairs yeah okay but
even at that 12 grand a year i mean
and you've got almost a hundred thousand
dollars in debt from your consumer debt
plus the business debt and this is
outside of the rental correct
in your home yeah that
yes okay well that just about just the
consumer debt which i'm not adding in
you know the whole
business is about 40 000. yeah it's just
i think you're you're doing a lot of
different things right now and i i think
it's going if it's not already adding
stress to your life which i assume you
wouldn't be calling in if it wasn't
creating some level of anxiety going all
right we've got a lot of things going on
here so what i would recommend you do uh
the business debt i mean you signed your
personal name on that debt right
yeah well yes it was through the
business when i bought it but it was my
personal name you know i'm owner of the
business so anything that's not real
estate i would go ahead and put in baby
step 2 in this debt snowball and listed
out from smallest to largest do you have
any cash right now just straight up in
the savings
just
just my emergency fund for my business
which is around a thousand dollars and
then i have an emergency fund for my
personal liking baby step two was a
thousand dollars
okay so you're in baby step two now
we're gonna use the debt snowball so i
what i want you to do is list out all of
your debts that aren't real estate and
list them out from smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate and i
want you to start attacking that with a
vengeance with every dollar you can get
coming in we're not buying anything
we're not swiping the credit card
anymore we're not buying cars if you can
sell some of those cars and make a
profit off of it i would do that as well
are they are they in good shape could
you get some money for those cars and
clear some of this debt uh it would be
close uh i might be able to it'd be very
very close
i'd look into it right now because i'm
seeing some crazy things with this car
market where people are getting uh way
over the the value that would have been
you know 18 months ago so if that can
speed up this journey for you i want you
to clear this hundred thousand dollars
of debt and be in a really good spot for
you to eventually start building more
cabins with cash
all right and that's kind of why i felt
too but i felt good to hear from
somebody else yeah thanks for the call
josh and here's the deal you can knock
this out and once you knock this
personal debt out knock that cabin out
now all of a sudden uh you've got some
real uh wealth building opportunity here
and and and then then expand that
business because clearly it's working
and so that's a positive asset in the
sense that okay we've got something to
build off of but don't don't take the
temptation to take on more debt yep yeah
that's a good move but he's got he's got
some good things going on but again when
i hear credit cards and the cars and
personal loans it feels like things are
out of whack right now we've got to
clean up the mess before we can focus on
growing the business george i was going
to ask you this um
are you sensing because i know you look
into consumer stuff as well
are you sensing any trend here on are we
going to see used car costs
kind of slow down feels like they're
pretty high a premium right now is that
going to change anytime soon are you
reading anything my prediction is in
2022 we're going to see things level out
a little bit we're not going to see this
craziness where used cars are going for
you know 30
more than they would have 18 months ago
as the supply chain starts to fix itself
when we see more new cars in the market
the used cars will get a little less
attractive and so right now if you've
got car debt now's the time to look into
some of these sites like vroom and
carvana
carmax dealerships even facebook
marketplace i've been hearing crazy
stories of people listing their car on
facebook marketplace and dealers from
different states are contacting them and
they're legit and they're saying we'll
give you way over uh your offer oh so
you're saying to go to a car dealer
which is traditionally an awful idea
because they give you way less yeah
kelly and listing on facebook
marketplace and the dealer reaches out
to you so you're getting kelly blue book
value from car dealers oh yeah why even
more oh they're desperate out there
this this is why crazy this is why he's
the consumer's friend right my nerd good
stuff hey don't move more of your calls
coming up
he's george campbell i'm ken coleman and
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined by
george campbell as we take your
questions this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five the number to
jump in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five now of course we take
your calls but we also get
you know a show this large tremendous
amount of social media questions um and
i should mention if you wanna follow
george and i on the gram as the kids
call it instagram
do cats call it i don't think kids call
it that but i'll give it to you
i did that i knew i was gonna anytime
you say as the kids call it just know
it's not what they well i you know i
slipped into dad mode there george
because i have three teenagers and i do
that and recently the team got me on
tick-tock
that's right and i don't do anything
over there so this is not like go follow
me over there because i the team does it
and you know we're kind of you know
dabbling into some content there you're
not doing dance challenges don't get
excited we had a post that went kind of
nuts and i came home that day and i told
my kids hey uh so dad's pretty big on
the talk
and dude they were so irritated with
just like you are right now yeah that i
called it the talk but it's not the gram
either no it's instagram yeah at george
campbell at george campbell with a k and
at ken coleman yeah yeah also with a k
coleman with a c thank you jerry you
just confused everybody yeah we got a
lot a lot ramsey has a lot i don't have
many fans but the ramsey brand we get a
lot of social media questions so we love
them and you've got a very interesting
one right now yes we've got a great
question from joel on facebook and
here's what joel asked i got hit in the
t-mobile data breach earlier this year
and i keep getting weird voicemails and
texts from random companies should i be
worried about id theft that's a great
question ken if you didn't hear about
this back in august t-mobile had a data
breach that affected almost 50 million
customers i think i remember i think i
remember seeing a headline yeah so this
is scary stuff a lot of data breaches
out there at some point your life you're
going to be a part of a data breach i
mean a lot of major companies very scary
really yeah but here's the thing let me
explain to you and this will answer
joel's question a data breach is
different from identity theft so a data
breach just means that your information
was exposed so there was a security
breach and your personal confidential
information is out there someone may
have access to maybe your birthday your
email address maybe your social security
number your street address things like
that but it doesn't turn into identity
theft until someone actually uses that
private information uh for their
financial gain and i experienced
identity theft did you i had
someone opened up an att account a
verizon account under my name using my
nashville address but they did it in
boston with my social security number
and racked up seventeen hundred dollars
was this this was uh back in 2014. was
it uh did they at least uh re um when
they stole your identity were they like
a six foot five i was hoping i don't
know if they ever found the person but
here's the thing uh it was very scary
because you go this person has my very
personal information they used it
against me
to create this debt in my name that's
crazy obviously i didn't have to pay it
but they racked up seventeen hundred
dollars on both accounts uh and the good
news is i was working at ramsey at the
time i had id theft protection through
xander dave gets that for all the
employees but here's some things that
joel can do because i think it's a
legitimate worry to have i don't want
you to get paranoid about identity theft
you can sleep
sleep easy at night but here's some
things that you can do number one is
check your credit report what's really
interesting right now is the bureaus are
offering free weekly reports through
april 20th 2022
normally you can access them once a year
for free right now they're doing it
weekly through 2022 april 20th 2022
thanks to kovitz so that's one thing you
can do check for any suspicious activity
there another thing you can do and i did
this after identity theft is freeze your
credit so call up uh contact the three
credit bureaus and make sure you freeze
your credit that's equifax experian
transunion what that means is no one's
gonna be able to open up an account
because it's frozen you might have to
lift it temporarily right temporarily if
you're you know applying for an
apartment and there's a hard inquiry if
you need to do a check like that another
thing you can do beef up your password
game right most of us we don't we can't
remember our passwords we use the same
one on everything oops and that's a
dangerous move is it because if they get
your your password for your t-mobile
account that might be the same one for
your email and now they access a whole
web of things and so make sure you're
using strong passwords uh use a password
manager james childs our producer loves
a good password manager that's another
thing you can do he does he strikes me
as a privacy nerd yeah another thing
have you heard of this two-factor
authentication
um is that the deal where
this is gonna have to get a cell phone
number well yeah so you can do different
things see smarty pants i actually knew
a little bit you've got a password but
you also have to verify it through maybe
a text message
opening up a smartphone app or a
physical security key so those are all
great things but the number one thing i
tell you to do to sleep easy is just get
identity theft protection it's super
cheap for an individual it's you know
it's the cost of a latte and for a
family it's the cost of a pizza per
month to stay protected and what this
does this i didn't know this xander does
all the work for me they do and so
they're they're 24 7 365 support
and they will cover up to a million
dollars for stolen funds and expenses
and there's proactive monitor monitoring
and alerts so i love this i sleep easy
at night now i haven't had identity
theft since
and i do these other things you know i
freeze my credit i make sure my
passwords are strong and i use
two-factor authentication so that in
case of a breach it doesn't create
identity theft yeah i got to tell you
george i feel much better because when
you started off on this whole deal about
data breach i thought somebody was going
to break into the studio could cut some
guys in some black suits and you know
the aviator glasses it sounds very very
scary but i do recall that each month
you know i'm not a fan of email but i do
get an email from xander and i click on
it it tells me and they'll let you know
hey your email it was compromised um go
change your password here and i go oh
thank you zan i would have had no idea
yeah yeah so it there's it's a great
feature and there's a lot of things you
can do to protect yourself don't freak
out joel
but make sure that you're doing these
things good stuff good question thanks
george good stuff there megan is up now
in green bay wisconsin megan how can we
help
hi
i am so honored to talk to you guys well
thank you what's going
on all right so my husband has been
employed for 20 years with the skin
company longer than we've been married
actually
and his employer is implementing a
surcharge on insurance costs for those
who are not receiving the kodak shot um
which we definitely do not want
and so we're trying to figure out we we
don't know how much the surcharge is
going to be um and we're just looking
for some guidance as to where to go from
here if we should just kind of wait the
boat or if he should maybe just start
looking a little bit to see what else is
out there in case it gets you know
let me ask you this if this wasn't
coming down the pike
would he be thinking about moving on
no
he really likes what he does yeah
um
i this is i'm going to try to not get
involved in this emotionally and and
help you walk through this um because on
one hand you guys don't want to get it
you don't want to get the shot
and uh on the other hand you don't want
to you know get hit really hard and take
on an expense like this and he wasn't
looking wasn't thinking about looking
prior to this so this really puts you in
a tough situation but i think this comes
down to to your priorities
and uh you know
i think at the end of the day they need
to tell you what the what the cost is
going to be and then you weigh the cost
literally weigh the cost okay in order
to stay in this job that he really
enjoys
there's going to be an added monthly
expense now that i'm getting hit with
um how long is that going to last we
don't know the answer to that you know
is it going to be
forever you know
who knows
i think you have to weigh that um
while you're weighing that and waiting
for that information i would be looking
though i'll tell you that
yeah there's two pieces of this there's
the ethical component of do i want to
work for a place that has these values
and if overall he agrees with them
ethically and he goes all right this is
something i got to deal with and uh it
basically you know turns into a 200 pay
cut right if it's 10 15 bucks a month
now if it's i can't imagine it's
anything large i'm not gonna charge you
a hundred dollars i would hope not um
but then you weigh it and go all right
am i willing to take this
little pay cut uh to stay at a job that
i truly love and this is just an
annoyance that i'm gonna deal with as
part of it but if you're like hey i
can't agree with them ethically anymore
i've got to leave that's your decision
that you have to make yeah
yeah i i think this is tough um
and i got to tell you now that i think
about it george you know i i wouldn't be
surprised if it's not a hefty
bump because i'm gonna tell you what
this amounts to this is a penalty
and companies are saying we think
everybody should be vaccinated
and
we're telling you that you
need to
uh because i think delta airlines came
out they were the first i think major
company for this kind of thing was like
hey we're going to hit you with a with a
premium uh on your health care because
of all the uh the implications they're
saying yeah but i think it comes down to
a penalty
and i don't know it may not be it may
not be insignificant it may be a
significant number and in that case
unfortunately turns into a budget line
item your values and your money are
driving this decision and if you got to
move on you got to move on
hey don't move on because we've got more
of your calls coming up this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit go to
blinds.com and take advantage of this
week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
ramsey show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague
george campbell and we're here for you
this hour it is a free phone call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and george this is uh it's our favorite
part of the show looking out there in
the ramsey solutions lobby on the debt
free stage i see brandon and michaela
welcome thank you hello yeah where are
you guys from we're from paducah
paducah kentucky all right and uh if
you're on that stage that means you're
here for a debt free screening yes sir
fantastic how much debt did you pay off
we paid off 25
500 and then we also had a baby in the
middle of that whoa congratulations
thank you how old is the baby now she's
six months old six months are you
sleeping actually yeah she sleeps really
well she sleeps that really you sleep
that's fantastic okay so
thousand five hundred dollars how long
did it take ten months ten months and
what was the range of income uh it
started at a hundred thousand and then
it's up to 115. oh all right tell me
about that what what we do to get there
uh well actually it was just a race
through my work good about
about halfway through this year great
what do you do i'm a manager at a hvac
supply house nice and uh michaela i work
at a cpa office oh nice okay fantastic
so great income here um and uh what kind
of debt was the 25 500 um everything it
was a car loan student loans credit card
we financed some
flooring some carpet
everything really okay all right are you
happy with the flooring choice i love it
i love it
it's paid for now that's right it's paid
for so i hope you're happy it feels a
little bit better to walk on wonderful
yeah i thought that might be the case
okay uh so ten months ago
uh did you know about ramsey solutions
financial peace the total money makeover
what what led you to start this journey
you can take it okay uh so i had
actually known about dave ramsey for a
while um i had
i had done fpu probably two or three
times okay and
i knew how it worked i just never did it
never really
i guess was motivated to do it and
i guess it was towards the end of
december of last year we were like okay
we're really going to do this so we
downloaded every dollar app and we
started doing it for real and
then we got pregnant yeah
yeah how did that how did that because
you'd already started it then you find
out you're pregnant
well did that intensify it we found that
we were pregnant in what august
and we started in january oh i'm with
you i got you yeah do you think that may
have been the domino that i think yeah i
think it was definitely a
big factor yeah just to be prepared for
when she was here yeah sure
so what were the things you guys did
because that's a pretty big chunk even
of your income in 10 months to pay off
were there some sacrifices did you sell
anything get extra jobs
uh
well i mean we sacrificed eating out
which we love to do yeah come on no um
we did sell an older vehicle that we had
for
was it 5 000
but everything else was just
hard at it just get after us
what was what was uh
what was maybe one of the most difficult
things to kind of say no to or maybe one
of the most difficult things to do in
the middle of this journey
you want to answer that nope you can oh
geez you guys are so polite i feel like
you guys need paddles not really so you
guys can determine who's going next i
like that yeah
um
i would say the hardest thing was
probably you know we had friends that
hey you want to go do this you want to
go do that we're going to go here it's
like oh man we can't do that yeah
wow
i get that so did you have cheerleaders
were they cheering you on or do they
think you were weirdos for doing this
thing crazy yeah weirdos
actually our biggest cheerleader was my
younger brother which we kind of got
into this
and we gave him our older
what book was financial peace
total money makeover i'm sorry okay and
he was kind of hesitant at first and he
got really into it and he was cheering
for us the whole time so now he's doing
it so that's incredible i love that what
do you what would you tell people is the
key to winning this
waking up every day and making the
decision of i'm going to choose to be
debt-free i'm going to choose
to not live like i did before yeah and
consistency consistency consistency
and communication that's a theme right
here
consistency and communication i love
that wake up every day and choose to be
debt-free
it's a daily decision you can't just
decide once and then keep living your
life the way you were living you've got
to make some changes change some habits
make some sacrifices like you guys did
absolutely incredible so how does it
feel now wonderful amazing absolutely
wonderful yeah you could see it so how
has it changed you're a young couple how
has it changed your outlook on the
future now on the other side of this
you're now debt free what's it done for
your vision for the things you're
dreaming about i mean you know it's it's
kind of nice to wake up in the morning
and not you know on fridays when we get
paid it's like okay we get to keep this
you know it's not like it's going
everywhere else and now we've got a
little girl that you know she gets to
grow up and we get to race her in the
way that we've now been taught and
it's just endless opportunities really
and now you can eat out again what's
your what's the spot yeah that's what i
wanted free where did you go what was
the meal
we haven't had it yet yeah we're
planning on doing that this weekend oh
this weekend okay so really seriously
you've not been out to eat in in 10
months
not no not really are you guys going to
stay over you're going back to paducah
we're here for the weekend so we wanted
as
george i feel like during the break you
should go give them some suggestions
you're mister you're mr uh millennial no
this is my nashville eateries george
please do they haven't been inside of a
restaurant for 10 years 10 months ken i
gotta tell like ten years like george is
so fired up he's gonna give you so many
great suggestions i'm gonna leave now
please do now we gotta get to the screen
first that's the best part absolutely so
uh wow wow wow what a great story well
hey couple things before we get to the
screen uh we wanna give you a copy of
dave ramsey's the legacy journey because
this really is now the next step for you
guys uh truly building a legacy not with
just that beautiful little princess but
in everything you do
who you give to and how you spend that
money
so we want to give that to you and then
i love that you gave a total money
makeover to your brother because we're
going to give you a brand new copy
uh to give to somebody else and so that
is our gift and we want to give that to
you so that is just really good stuff
you guys are a great couple thank you
you guys are heroes
and uh this is why we do what we do
we're ready to celebrate you guys ready
to go ready you're ready to go okay here
we go
brandon and michaela from paducah
kentucky they paid off twenty five
thousand five hundred dollars in ten
months make it a hundred thousand
up to a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars brandon michaela take it away do
your debt free scream three two one
we're debt-free
there it is that's how it's done huh how
about that couple look at that i've her
face is changing just giant smile
plaster on the face yeah incredible yeah
i mean
they've done their debt free stream i'm
not sure what is leading to the big
smiles
the most is it their debt free uh
because they've been debt-free for
obviously a little bit to get here or is
it the excitement about the restaurant
suggestions you're gonna get it's the
upcoming meal ken nashville's got a lot
of great food they're in the right place
and they're in the right hands but you
know we're having fun with that but
that seems like a little sacrifice
but it's not dangling that little carrot
is really powerful to go hey what do we
want to do once we're dead free what
kind of things we want to do again or
for the first time and it's one of those
things where you go we don't have to
think about it it's in the budget we're
going to pay cash for it we're going to
have a great time yeah but instead of
wondering yeah do we have the money am i
going to put this on the credit card
yeah but speak to this george you coach
people on this i mean
you start
racking up things like i'm not going to
go out to eat we're going to you know do
this this this all those things together
add up to where you can pay off 25 grand
in 10 months which is that's a lot of
money in 10 months so what happens is
you go we're going to make a temporary
sacrifice for a long-term gain when you
have that kind of mindset it changes
everything most people go i'm just going
to keep living this way for the next 20
years and i'll worry about it down the
road they keep kicking the can down the
road and one day
they realize hopefully they're broke and
they're miserable they're living with
anxiety and they can't reach their
dreams and buy homes and go on vacations
and it's all because of that and so i
love meeting couples like this who
decide and not only decide but wake up
every day deciding that it doesn't have
to be this way and we're going to dangle
this carrot this goal in front of us of
debt freedom and all the things that
comes with that so that we can power
through and pay this off i love it all
right george um i want to know you go 10
months without eating out
where do you go what kind of meal just
tell me the meal i think it's got to be
a high quality meat i'm probably going
rib eye okay that's just me yeah i asked
you maybe a big old pork shop okay
what's your side uh i'm gonna go with
mashed potatoes really maybe some
asparagus i'm a little shocked that you
chose mashed potatoes it's creamy it's
buttery it's filling
oh i love it i gotta tell you if i go
ten months without a meal i'm gonna have
to work in some amazing seafood george
maybe a surf and turf
you know a little bit of maybe a fillet
and a giant lobster this is helping my
decisions for this guy there it is folks
this is what you come here for hey don't
move it's not done yet more of your
calls more breakthrough coming up this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
the ramsay show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell so thrilled that you've joined
us today triple eight eight two five
five two two five as we talk about your
life
our scripture of the day is matthew 7
13-14
enter through the narrow gate for wide
is the gate and broad is the road that
leads to destruction and many enter
through it but small is the gate and
narrow the road that leads to life
and only a few find it today's quote
comes from john maxwell the secret of
your success is determined by your daily
agenda good stuff there
amarillo texas is where we go now and
chancellor joins us on the line there
chancellor how can we help hey yes sir
thanks guys for taking my phone call you
bet
hey hey
so
kind of crazy here
i
am in a point at a point now to where we
are my wife and i were completely out of
debt
and uh we've been doing the we did the
baby steps and we got gazelle intense
and
it seems
as if the gazelle intensity has kind of
taken over our lives
we don't really know where to go from
here and it's not a bad situation by any
means you know we have
a nice savings account 15 going to
retirement and
we got our kids
college funds on the way we're building
them
however we still have an influx of money
and we don't know what to do
now
so you've got leftover cash after four
and five and you're wondering what do we
do with it
yes sir how much money are we talking
uh right now we have about fifty six
thousand dollars in cash
that's on top of your emergency fund
yes well that's no no i'm sorry 41 000
we have 56 000 total
okay 41 000 is your emergency fund
15 000. oh okay
okay so we got 15 in the emergency fund
what's outside of the emergency fund in
cash
41 000
okay there we go all right now we're
cooking with gas so you've got baby step
six paying off the house early and
you're saying hey we've been going real
hard is it okay for us to slow down and
enjoy our lives
uh
uh yeah i guess so um i guess
my fear
is you know with college prices being
college tuition being so expensive
i just don't know how much
what's the cap where to stop where to
start i mean
really just
right yeah i mean my kids are my biggest
how old are these kids yeah that's fine
well i have a nine-year-old stepson and
i have a one-year-old daughter
okay we've got 17 years till college and
we've got another nine years till
college you've got plenty of time you
guys have done really well
i'm not super worried about them being
able to afford going to college
debt-free
with the way you guys have handled your
finances is that what you're worried
about will be will we be able to afford
it
um yeah
i am worried about that i am
um
but more or less you know i i would like
uh
i like my kids you know i'm i'm 27 years
old i i
my last 29 but i fear every day that i
just don't want my kids
needing anything
ever
yeah does that make sense well i mean
you're a great dad for wanting that but
i don't want you living in this fear
ever you said i'm living in fear every
day
uh and that borders on paranoia at that
point and so i want you guys to you guys
have done so well you've worked so hard
you have 41 thousand dollars sitting
there in liquid cash so have some fun
have you guys been on a vacation
well we do we do enjoy our vacation but
we do
chancellor can i speak to you as a dad
uh of three
i totally understand your heart that you
don't want your kids to want for
anything but the way that sounds
is if
you have the pressure that you've put on
yourself
to fund their entire life
the way you said it sounded way more
than college
and george has already made it clear
you're going to be fine on college fund
and you just keep doing what we teach
there and they're gonna be fine they're
gonna have plenty
but this idea that i don't want my kids
to want for anything i completely
understand that believe me i understand
you
but your job is not to fund their life
they're gonna they have a role that they
were created to fill there's work they
want to do there's dreams that they have
it's that's on them to do that it's not
on you to fund their entire life
okay
okay you needed to hear that didn't you
yes sir
yeah man yes sir you're a good dude
you're a good dude
look the baby steps are the baby steps
you're doing it man keep walking it out
relax
outside of that
your kids are going to make their own
decisions
you
your job is not to now look if you want
to do a mutual fund and something for
them down the road and give them a great
start whatever and put some nice strings
on all that that's all good but again i
feel this heavy weight on you that needs
to be released today
okay so
i guess that leads me into my next
question um
what could i start doing you know like i
i have a really good job i can't
complain about my job however i don't
absolutely love my job
but
you know i
i have this dream of
you know working for myself
tell me what that would be
i don't care how pretty it sounds and
how great of a business plan you have
tell me what right now in this very
moment
you would do for yourself
if you knew you couldn't fail what kind
of business what would you do
and honestly i think i would do
landscaping
it's fantastic i truly love landscaping
i've done it i did it
okay now listen
chancellor you're in a position man
where you can start to plan this out and
start this thing on the side with no
risk
how much money do you make in your
current job
well it's a little bit
it fluctuates quite a bit but i'd say
between 130 and 150. all right so let's
let's just pick 150 as a number you
would want to replace it if i promised
you that you could make 150
today
running your landscaping business how
quickly would you resign
right now
that's it my man so here's the deal what
is it going to take for you
to eventually start that business
and take care of your family
in that business there's a couple ways
you could do this you could keep busting
it the way you're busting it you got
some money right here george he's got
some money that can begin to be the seed
for starting that landscaping business
and maybe you do it on the side you hire
a couple young guys and you're the face
of it and
you build this thing up you build it up
and you get
enough money in that landscaping
business account that you've got six
months of your salary there and you know
if i just go at this full time i've got
the pipeline full i can go this becomes
a math
equation
that's right
start today
start pursuing today by planning and
thinking through how would i do it
what's the best way to do it save it all
up and step into it or start it on the
side and establish it i really like
starting it on the side and establishing
it by the way
and chancellor you can do that now can
you not
yes sir i actually you know i have about
10 yards a week i do right now oh look
at that i had a sneaky suspicion george
that he was already my yard's next man
that's i'm so glad people have a passion
for landscaping ken because i have zero
yeah so listen man you have done so well
you're 27 years old you make a hundred
fifty thousand dollars you're in baby
step six you have a pile of cash
you need to let go of this fear and
start getting excited about your life
again your kids are gonna be fine you
need to start dreaming and uh really
going after this thing like ken's
talking about yeah and you've got it
chancellor those 10 yards every nickel
that you make
or rather keep after you pay for the you
know the lawn care equipment and all the
things in gas right
that's just going in that side account
and i'm building that side account up
and i'm building it and i'm building it
and i'm building it and i'm trying to
figure out can i put six months of my
salary what i currently make in that
account and i'm building up the clients
and i'm going i know that i can blow
this thing wide open and there's no risk
here george you know we talk about
stepping from the boat right on the dock
that's what this side hustle is
and then he's going to be in such great
financial shape
that he doesn't have the pressure that a
lot of entrepreneurs face it's amazing
how many times people get their
financial life in order and then they
can focus on purpose and career it's
incredible yeah if only we had somebody
hit ramsey solutions that could help
them figure out that dream cough oh wait
a second wait we can do that
fun stuff hey i want to thank you george
we had a great time today we did fun
stuff man great great job always great
to be with you i want to thank our
amazing producer james childs and
equally amazing associate producer and
college greener kelly daniel i mostly
want to thank you america for listening
because we do this for you this is your
show this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you